فريق تطوعي من الجنسين في مدينه جده يقوم
بانقاذ قطط الاحياء الخاضعه للتطوير في
المدينه وايضا في مكه المكرمه نتابعه
في بادره انسانيه لرفق بالحيوان يشارك
358 متطوعه ضمن فريق رحماء في انقاذ قطط
الاحياء الخاضعه لتطوير بمدينه مكه
المكرمه وجده ونقلها الى احياء امنه بدات
الفكره
احياء كثير في مدينه جده نقل السكان اللي
فيها الى اماكن اخرى فبقيه القطط في هذه
الاماكن بدون اكل وبدون شرب فراينا هذه
المشكله في حبينا ان نكون حل او جزء من
الحيه هذه المشكله فريق محمد التطوعي يقوم
بعلاج واحتضان القطط المصابه ومتابعه
حالتها الى ان تتماثل للشفاء ثم عرضها
للتبني بعد ان تنتهي مرحله علاجها
والعنايه بها اعداد الحيوانات اللي همم
حتى الان يعني نجحت وهممورها تمام
55 همم
الحالات اللي تم علاج حالات يعني
كانت مره مشوها وفي بعضها اللي كان وضعها
خفيف بس يعني اغلبها كانت سيارات صدمتهم
عندهم كسر عندهم اشياء من هذا القبيل
محتاجين محتاجين عمليات عشان يتعالجوا
عشان يخرجوا من الحاله الصحيه السيئه اللي
كانوا فيها نجاح الفريق وفي انقاذ نحو سته
الاف قطه واطعام في هذا العدد وايجاد
متبانين لعدد من القطط في 20 حيا غاضعا
للتطوير في العاصمه المقدسه وجده وصلنا
لهذا العدد ونطم انه يزيد عن كده وانه
نقدر فعلا نكون مركز يستقبل جميع انواع
الحيوانات المتضرر اللي ما عندها يعني بعد
الله احد انه يعالجها واحنا نتكفل بها
ونقدر نساهم في هذا الشيء من اهدافه فريق
روحه ماء نشر الوعي في المجتمع بالرفق
بالحيوان وانقاذ القطط والحيوانات التي
تحتاج الى رعايه وتشجيع تبني الحيوانات
التي لها محمد الزهراني العربيه جدا